Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. For fans of the England football team, Tom, the subject of today's podcast is something of a sore point because four years ago when the World Cup was held in Russia, England went on a remarkable run to reach the semi-finals but were knocked out by the eventual runners-up Croatia and um Croatia
感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史余音》。对于英格兰足球队的球迷来说，汤姆，今天播客的主题可以说是他们的痛处，因为四年前世界杯在俄罗斯举办时，英格兰一路高歌猛进杀入半决赛，却被最终的亚军克罗地亚淘汰了，而且克罗地亚
is a wonderful country fascinating history Tom you've chosen a subject from Croatian history to focus on today and who or what are you talking about Croatian-ish because the the focus is um a period long before the creation of the modern state of Croatia okay and the focus is a period long before the creation of the modern state of Croatia. Okay. And the focus is a man called, he was born Diocles in the 3rd century AD, early 240s AD at a place called Salona. And today, if you've been to the city of Split, Solin is still there. It's a suburb of Split now. But back in the 3rd century AD, it belonged to a region called Dalmatia, which in turn was part of a region of the empire called
是一个绝佳的国家，有着迷人的历史。汤姆，你今天选择了一个克罗地亚历史上的主题作为焦点，你所说的是谁或者什么？之所以说是“类克罗地亚”，是因为我们的焦点是一个远在现代克罗地亚国建立之前的时期。好的。我们的焦点是一个远在现代克罗地亚国建立之前的时期。好的。而我们的焦点是一个名叫狄奥克莱斯的男子，他于公元3世纪、即公元240年代早期出生在一个叫萨罗纳的地方。今天，如果你去过斯普利特这座城市，索林依然还在。它现在是斯普利特的一个郊区。但在公元3世纪，它属于一个叫达尔马提亚的地区，而达尔马提亚又是帝国一个地区的组成部分，被称为
Illyricum. So Tom, just to jump in for one second. So those people who don't know much about Croatian history, but maybe have been to Croatia, if they've been through Split, they will have seen, won't they, one of the most extraordinary Roman buildings still standing, which is Diocletian's palace, which is basically the city centre of Split. Yes, it is. And you may be wondering, what's the link between this chap Diocletian and Diocletian? Well, all will be revealed in due course, because Diocletian is a figure from a very, very obscure background. He's the son of a scribe who may have been a freedman or may actually have been a slave. So Diocles may conceivably have been born unfree. So he comes absolutely from the bottom of the pile. And yet amazingly,
伊利里库姆。所以汤姆，我打断一下。对于那些对克罗地亚历史了解不多，但可能去过克罗地亚的人来说，如果他们去过斯普利特，他们一定见过至今仍存的最非凡的罗马建筑之一，那就是狄奥克莱修宫，它基本上就是斯普利特的市中心。是的，确实如此。你可能会想，这位叫狄奥克莱的家伙和狄奥克莱修之间有什么联系？这一切都会在适时的时候揭晓，因为狄奥克莱修是一个出身非常非常卑微的人物。他是一个抄写员的儿子，那个抄写员可能是一个释奴，也可能实际上是个奴隶。所以狄奥克莱出生成为自由人的可能性很小。因此，他绝对是社会最底层的人。然而令人惊叹的是，
Diocles will become Diocletian. I'm giving away the twist. He rules as emperor for over 20 years from 284 to 305. So how is it possible that someone from the bottom of the social order could have risen to become not just emperor, but ruling for two decades? And the answer to that lies in the circumstances into which he is born, which is one of utter convulsion and chaos for the Roman Empire. It's basically a kind of 50-year period of anarchy that almost sees the Roman order implode completely. And it's in conditions of chaos that people from outside the social elites can rise to the top. And this is what people call the crisis of the third century, isn't it? Crisis doesn't really do it justice. So essentially, it sees the entire order of the Roman Empire as it had been set up by Augustus, and which had prevailed for essentially two
狄奥克莱将成为狄奥克莱修。我把悬念剧透了。他作为皇帝统治了20多年，从公元284年到305年。那么，一个社会底层的人怎么可能不仅崛起成为皇帝，而且统治了长达二十年呢？这个问题的答案在于他出生的环境，那是罗马帝国遭遇彻底动荡和混乱的时期。这基本上是一个长达50年的无政府状态时期，几乎导致罗马的秩序完全崩溃。正是在这种混乱的环境中，社会精英之外的人才能爬到顶峰。这就是人们所说的三世纪危机，对吧？“危机”这个词实在无法贴切形容它。所以本质上，它使得奥古斯都建立的、并在基本上持续了两个世纪之久的整个罗马帝国秩序
centuries. It sees it pretty much on its uppers. So the essence of the Augustan settlement, the imperial order that he creates out of the collapse of the Republic, which had been the previous kind of great process of convulsion and near collapse that the Roman order had gone through, is that it's an autocracy. You have rule by one man, an imperator comes, you know, the emperor. But that it is done in association with the Senate. And Augustus pretends that he is less powerful than he actually is. And the Senate has the illusion that it is more powerful than it really is. And so senators, they rise up through a kind of chain of military and civilian commands. And they're providing the emperor with the elites
几乎陷入山穷水尽的境地。因此，奥古斯都体制的精髓——即他在共和国崩溃（罗马秩序经历过的上一次重大动荡和近乎崩溃的过程）的废墟上建立的帝国秩序——是一个专制政体。你拥有由一人统治的政权，一个统帅（imperator，也就是皇帝）出现了。但这种统治是与元老院联合进行的。奥古斯都假装自己的权力比实际要小。而元老院则产生了一种自己比实际更有权力的错觉。因此，元老院成员通过某种军事和民事职务的晋升链条不断上升。他们为皇帝提供了
that enable the empire to be administered. And this had served the Roman order very well for about two centuries. But then in the third century, it all goes to pot. And it's a vast kind of conflux of circumstances that we don't really have time to focus in on. And I think that we should do maybe a series of episodes on this process because it's very, very interesting.
使帝国得以治理的精英阶层。这套体制曾很好地服务了罗马秩序大约两个世纪。但在公元3世纪，这一切都彻底搞砸了。这是一个极其庞大的各种情况的交汇，我们其实没有时间去详细关注。我认为我们应该制作一系列关于这个过程的节目，因为这非常非常有趣。
And maybe mildly topical when we look at the state of Britain and Europe at the moment. Oh, no, Tom, don't say that. But, you know, if we want to cheer ourselves up now, things were far, far worse in the Roman Empire in the third century. So what you have, you have huge pressure on the frontiers. So you have the barbarians along the Rhine and the Danube, which had always been there,
当我们审视目前英国和欧洲的现状时，这或许还有点时代切合性。哦，不，汤姆，别这么说。但是，你知道，如果我们现在想让自己振作起来，公元3世纪罗马帝国的情况要糟糕得多得多。所以你会发现，边境面临着巨大的压力。莱茵河和多瑙河沿岸有蛮族，
but they're kind of tribal entities that are conglomerating. So they're able to execute more and more pressure. But the real problem is, is that in the East, the Parthian Empire, which had been a rather ramshackle entity, has collapsed and been replaced by a much more aggressive and efficient imperial order under a Persian dynasty called the
他们一直都在那里，但他们正在聚合成某种部落实体。因此，他们能够施加越来越多的压力。但真正的问题在于，在东方，安息帝国曾经是一个相当松散的实体，如今已经崩溃，并被一个在波斯王朝统治下更加咄咄逼人、更有效率的帝国秩序所取代，这个王朝被称为
Sassanids, so the Sasanian Empire. And that is a superpower fit to rival Rome. So for the first time, it's up against a kind of equal power. And that generates huge pressure. At the same time, within the fabric of the empire itself, you have a succession of civil wars people grasping after the uh the the the imperial purple being dispatched so you know at various points you have maybe three four five people in very very rapid succession um in charge so you have civil war you have external war the the consequent effect of this is the collapse of the tax base. You see fields, particularly along the frontiers, turning to weeds. Cities are left as charred and pillaged piles of rubble. So these are regions that are no longer paying taxes. As a result, the emperors need to impose ever higher taxes
萨珊王朝，即萨珊帝国。那是一个足以与罗马匹敌的超级大国。因此，罗马首次面对一个势均力敌的力量。这产生了巨大的压力。与此同时，在帝国自身的结构内部，你经历了一连串的内战，人们争夺帝位（即帝国紫色长袍），然后被除掉；所以在各个时期，你可能会有大约三、四、五个人以非常非常快的速度掌权。因此，你经历了内战、外部战争，随之而来的影响就是税基的崩溃。你看到田地，特别是边境沿线的田地，长满了野草。城市沦为烧焦和劫掠的废墟堆。所以这些地区不再纳税。因此，皇帝们不得不对那些
on those who can pay. That in turn generates economic collapse. Economic collapse in turn generates famine. On top of that, you get cycles of plague starting to sweep in. Remember we had an episode with Karl Harper on this? Yeah. Absolutely kind of horrendous process. So it's a terrible state of affairs. And essentially, in this process of anarchy, the one key institution, the only institution that is capable of maintaining some kind of order.
能够纳税的人征收越来越高的税。这反过来又导致了经济崩溃。经济崩溃又反过来导致了饥荒。最糟糕的是，瘟疫周期开始席卷而来。还记得我们和卡尔·哈珀做过的那期节目吗？是的。那绝对是一个极其可怕的过程。所以局势极其糟糕。本质上，在这个无政府状态的过程中，唯一一个能够维持某种秩序的关键机构、唯一的机构
It's not the Senate. It's the army. Right. Because these emperors who are rising and falling, are these generally rival commanders, basically, being elevated by their troops? Yes, by and large. And to begin with, they're from the senatorial class. But increasingly, with all the pressure that you're getting on the frontiers, the absolute kind of requirement for efficient military leadership, having some kind of amateur guy come in for a couple of years is inadequate. You need a professional officer class.
不是元老院。而是军队。没错！因为这些不断兴衰的皇帝，基本上都是被他们的军队推举出来的敌对指挥官吗？是的，大体上是这样的。一开始，他们来自元老院阶层。但随着边境压力的不断增大，对高效军事领导的绝对需求也随之增加，让某种业余人士上台干上一两年是远远不够的。你需要一个职业军官阶层。
And so what happens over the course of the third century is that you get this kind of elite army corps, protectores, they are called, who start to replace the senators as people in charge of the legions and the auxiliary forces. And most of these tend to come from the Balkans. They're called Illyriki, so they're from Illyricum. And that's because these are tough, brutal guys who are not produced from the flesh pots of Italy. They are raised to fight. And they are essentially the most effective military operators in the empire. Senators hate them, of course, but more and more they are coming to run the army.
所以在整个三世纪期间发生的事情是，你拥有了这种被称为“近卫军”（protectores）的精锐军队核心，他们开始取代元老院成员，成为掌管军团和辅助部队的人。这些人大多来自巴尔干地区。他们被称为伊利里基人（Illyriki），也就是来自伊利里库姆。这是因为他们是一群坚韧、残酷的家伙，不是在意大利的温柔乡里温养出来的。他们是为战斗而生的人。而且他们基本上是帝国中最有战斗力的军事执行者。元老院当然恨他们，但他们越来越多地开始掌控军队。
And this is the background into which Diocles, who is, you know, he's from Illyricum. This is what he's born into. And Gibbon, who, you know, his account of the decline of the Roman Empire is the great narrative account of this process, says of Diocles that his abilities were useful rather than splendid. And I guess that that sums up the whole kind of warrior caste from Illyricum. They are useful, they're not splendid. They do not have a background in Virgil. They are not able to construe Greek poetry. They do not have a knowledge of philosophy, but their abilities are very, very useful in a time of invasion and civil war.
这就是狄奥克莱出生并成长的背景，他来自伊利里库姆。这就是他诞生的世界。而吉本——他对罗马帝国衰亡的叙述是这一过程的伟大叙事记载——对狄奥克莱的评价是，他的能力“与其说是光彩夺目，不如说是实用”。我想这总结了来自伊利里库姆的整个武士阶层的特点。他们很实用，并不光彩夺目。他们没有维吉尔的背景。他们无法解读希腊诗歌。他们没有哲学知识，但在入侵和内战的时代，他们的能力非常非常实用。
They're kind of hardheaded military, ruthless fixers. Yes. And in a way, the paradox is that Diocles, you know, he has no real education beyond that, that his father as a scribe can give him. So he's literate, but he doesn't have the kind of the equivalent of, you know, a doctorate from Oxford or, you know, being to Stanford, that kind of level. He doesn't have that. But what he does have is a sense of himself as Roman in the traditional sense, the traditional hard, tough kind of early Republican sense, the turnip eating peasant who goes out and defeats the Samnites or the Carthaginians, that kind of thing. He's aware of that. And he's a very pious person. He feels that the dues have to be paid to the traditional gods and that perhaps the traditional dues haven't been paid. And this is why the gods are punishing the Roman people. So although he would be despised by a senator as a barbarian, he sees himself as a deeply, deeply Roman figure. And so he's very proud to serve in the Roman army. He's very good at it. He rises to the command of a squadron of troops on the Danube. And meanwhile, as he is rising up through the ranks of the army, what you are seeing is people from Illyricum not just rising to the command of legions, but becoming emperors. And they prove themselves to be excellent emperors.
他们是一群精明的军人、冷酷无情的危机处理者。是的。从某种意义上说，这里的悖论在于，狄奥克莱除了他父亲作为抄写员能教给他的那些东西之外，并没有接受过真正的教育。所以他识字，但他没有那种相当于牛津博士学位，或者去过斯坦福那种级别的学历。他没有那些。但他拥有的是一种对自己的传统罗马认同感，那种传统的、坚定的、强硬的早期共和时代的感觉，就像那个走出去击败萨姆尼特人或迦太基人的吃芜菁的农民一样，就是那种感觉。他意识到了这一点。而且他是一个非常虔诚的人。他觉得必须向传统神明履行职责，而也许传统的职责并没有得到履行。这就是神明惩罚罗马人民的原因。因此，尽管他会被元老院议员鄙视为蛮族，但他自认为是一个极其极其传统的罗马人。所以他为能在罗马军队服役感到非常自豪。他在军队里表现得非常出色。他晋升为多瑙河流域一个骑兵中队的指挥官。与此同时，当他在军队军阶中不断晋升时，你所看到的是，来自伊利里库姆的人不仅升任军团指挥官，而且成为了皇帝。事实证明，他们是非常优秀的皇帝。
So what sort of names are we talking about, Tom? So there's a guy called Claudius, who- Right. Not the Claudius. Not the Claudius who conquers Britain, but the Claudius who people who listen to our episode on St. Valentine's Day may remember that we talked about. There's a Claudius who supposedly executed a Valentine. This is the Claudius. But he's a very effective leader. He defeats an enormous Gothic invasion over the Danube.
那么我们说的是什么样的名字呢，汤姆？这里有一个叫克劳狄乌斯的人，他——没错。不是那个克劳狄乌斯。不是那个征服英国的克劳狄乌斯，而是听过我们关于圣瓦伦丁节那期节目的听众可能还记得的那个克劳狄乌斯。有一个据说处决了圣瓦伦丁的克劳狄乌斯。这就是那个克劳狄乌斯。但他是一个非常有效的领导者。他在多瑙河击败了一次庞大的哥特人入侵。
You have a guy called Aurelian who at a time when the empire is falling apart at the seams you've got people declaring independence in gaul in the east all over the place he stitches it all back together very very effectively he's also the guy who builds the walls around rome itself yeah uh which is a real kind of measure of the time that even the even the the eternal city needs protection and then you have a guy called probus who right who as his name implies is is he goes in hard he goes in deep and uh thanks for that tom and and he he rose for about six years and he's very very militarily successful and he he he pushes back uh again anyone who dares to kind of cross the Rhine,
你有一个叫奥勒良的家伙，在帝国四分五裂、高卢和东方到处都有人宣布独立的时期，他非常非常有效地把这一切重新缝合在一起。他也是那个在罗马城周围修建城墙的人。是的，这确实是对那个时代的真实写照，甚至连永恒之城也需要保护。然后你有一个叫普罗布斯的家伙，正如他的名字所暗示的那样，他行事强硬、深入，感谢你的补充，汤姆。他统治了大约六年，在军事上非常非常成功。他再次击退了任何胆敢跨越莱茵河、
the Danube, the frontier with Persia. And in fact, at the end of his life, he's preparing the invasion of Mesopotamia, which is very traditional Roman behavior. Carrying the fight to the enemy. Carrying the fight to the enemy. And also he feels able to kind of reinstate a form of the the traditional constitutional order the um the the traditional relationship between the emperor and the senate so he's he's kind of feeling that he's able to inch his way back to to restoring that traditional relationship um and that may be why when he dies inevitably in a mutiny that you know this is happening all the time, the guy who follows him, a guy called Carus, I mean, he's the kind of figure who you might recognize from the second century. He's born in Gaul. He's been raised in Rome. He's a senator. His rise through the ranks, it's not just been military. He's also held civic offices. And in a way, as it will turn out out he's almost the last of a kind so he perhaps is the
多瑙河以及与波斯边境的人。事实上，在他生命的尽头，他正准备入侵美索不达米亚，这非常符合传统的罗马行为。把战火烧到敌人本土。把战火烧到敌人本土。而且他还觉得能够恢复某种传统的宪政秩序，也就是皇帝与元老院之间的传统关系。所以他觉得自已能够一步步地恢复那种传统关系。这也许就是为什么当他在一场兵变中不可避免地丧命时——这事总是不断发生——接替他的人，一个名叫卡鲁斯的家伙，我的意思是，他是一个你可能会从公元二世纪认出的人物。他出生在高卢。他在罗马长大。他是一名元老院议员。他通过军阶的晋升，不仅仅是通过军事途径。他还担任过市政职务。某种程度上，正如后来所证明的那样，他几乎是同类中的最后一人。所以他或许是
last of these traditional civilian augustan figures who rises to become emperor but he's only in power for about nine months um he rushes out he takes control of the um uh the invasion that probus had been preparing of mesopotamia a bit like alexander taking over after philip is murdered and he launches an invasion of Mesopotamia. It all goes tremendously well. He captures Ctesiphon, the capital of the Sassanid Empire. The Sassanid king is very distracted by civil wars himself. Diocles goes as commander of his cavalry. The commander of the Praetorians, a man called Arius Appa is also there. All seems to be going splendidly. And then Carus dies in the summer of 283,
最后一个历经晋升成为皇帝的传统文职奥古斯都式人物。但他只执掌权力大约九个月。他匆忙赶去，控制了普罗布斯一直在准备的美索不达米亚入侵行动，有点像亚历山大在腓力被谋杀后接管政权一样，他发动了对美索不达米亚的入侵。一切都进行得异常顺利。他攻占了萨珊帝国的首都泰西封。萨珊国王自己也被内战搞得焦头烂额。狄奥克莱作为他的骑兵指挥官同行。近卫军长官、一个名叫阿里乌斯·阿帕的人也在那里。一切似乎都在顺利进行。然后卡鲁斯在公元283年夏天去世了，
so nine months after he became emperor. And the story is that he got struck by lightning. Oh, that's bad luck. Gets incinerated by a lightning bolt. That's incredible bad luck, Tom. It is. And it's such incredible bad luck that inevitably people have wondered whether it really was credible. But let's say it did
也就是他成为皇帝九个月后。故事说他是被闪电击中的。哦，那太倒霉了。被雷击化为灰烬。这真是难以置信的厄运，汤姆。确实如此。这太难以置信了，以至于人们不可避免地会怀疑它是否真的可信。不过假设它确实
happen. So Charis has two sons. One is a guy called Carinus, who is back in Rome. And the other is a guy called Numerian, very Tolkien-esque name, I think, who is there with him and with the legions. Oh, I know what happens to Numerian. But go on, tell the story. I love this story. Numerian is proclaimed kind of co-emperor with his brother, Carinus, back in Rome. And they decide to withdraw because Numerian wants to go back and make sure that he's not going to be stabbed in the back by his brother. They're marching back, very slow process back.
发生了。所以卡鲁斯有两个儿子。一个是名叫卡里努斯的家伙，他在罗马；另一个是名叫努梅里安的家伙——我觉得这个名字非常托尔金风格——他和卡鲁斯以及军团在一起。哦，我知道努梅里安怎么了！但接着说，讲讲这个故事吧。我喜欢这个故事。努梅里安被宣布与他在罗马的兄弟卡里努斯共同担任皇帝。他们决定撤退，因为努梅里安想回去确保自己不会被兄弟从背后捅刀子。他们开始撤退，回程的进展非常缓慢。
Numerian ends up being confined to his litter. And Arius Appa, the Praetorian prefect, says that this is because he's got bad eyes. You you know he can't wear shades the sun is very bright in his eyes so he has the desert be bad for you it wouldn't be bad for your eyes tom he has to lie in his his litter with you know kind of wet flannel over his over his eyes and they go on and on back back and back and various soldiers who approach the litter start to report an unpleasant smell coming coming from the litter and arius appa says it's absolutely nothing he's he's the emperor is very well um he's got some personal hygiene problems, but which of us hasn't?
努梅里安最终被限制在轿子里。而近卫军长官阿里乌斯·阿帕说，这是因为他眼睛不好。你知道的，他不能戴墨镜，外面的阳光刺得他眼睛生疼，所以他必须待在沙漠里——这会对你的眼睛不好吗，汤姆？他不得不躺在轿子里，脸上盖着湿法兰绒之类的东西，他们就这样一路往回走。不断有靠近轿子的士兵报告说，轿子里散发出一股难闻的气味。而阿里乌斯·阿帕说这绝对没什么，皇帝非常好，他只是有一些个人卫生问题，但我们谁又没有呢？
And this is where Gibbon, ever skeptical, says, could no aromatics be found in the imperial household? And sure enough, they've reached the Bosphorus, Nicomedia, city south of what will become Constantinople on the south side. And they peep behind the curtain and there is numerian looking very very dead indeed presumably bright green by this point yes yeah he's really not looking good and there are there are two things to be decided the first is who is responsible for the for the death of numerian you know natural
正是在这里，一如既往持怀疑态度的吉本写道：“难道皇室里连一点芳香剂都找不到吗？”果不其然，他们到达了博斯普鲁斯海峡的尼科米底亚，那是后来君士坦丁堡南边的一座城市。他们掀开帘子一看，只见努梅里安看起来非常非常死透了。大概这个时候已经变成亮绿色了吧？是的，他确实看起来情况很不妙。有两件事需要决定：第一件是谁该为努梅里安的死负责，（是）自然死亡还是被谋杀；第二件是谁来接替他。其实有两个候选人，一个是近卫军长官阿里乌斯·阿帕，另一个是骑兵指挥官狄奥克莱。他们全都前往位于尼科米底亚海岸不远处的迦克敦参加一个军事会议。这基本上就是阿帕对阵狄奥克莱，看谁能成为皇帝。结果是狄奥克莱赢了。狄奥克莱获胜的理由是阿帕谋杀了努梅里安。嗯，这是一个合理的、合理的理由。是的，但我认为，考虑到我们史料的匮乏，以及狄奥克莱获胜并随后当了二十年皇帝这一事实，完全有可能他自己也参与其中——我的意思是，我们无从得知。
cause is always he murdered and the second is who's going to replace him and there are really two candidates one is arias app of the praetorian prefect and the other is diocles the commander of the horse and they they all head off to a kind of military council at chalcedon which is just up the coast from from nicomedia and it's basically it's appa against diocles who's going to become emperor and it's diocles who wins and diocles wins by saying that appa has murdered numerian well it's a reasonable a reasonable yes but i think a bit but the the paucity of our sources and the fact that that diocles wins and is then emperor for two decades it means it's perfectly possible that perhaps he did i I mean, we don't know.
（续）是的，当然。但基本上接下来发生的事情是：在284年11月下旬，狄奥克莱回到尼科米底亚城外的一座小山上，采用了这个显赫的名字：盖乌斯·奥勒留·瓦莱里乌斯·戴克里先（Gaius Aurelius Valerius Dioclesianus）。也就是在这座小山上，他成为了戴克里先（Diocletian）。随后，他让人把阿帕拖出来，用铁链锁着站在他身后，向集结的军团宣布阿帕就是杀害努梅里安的人。他拔出剑，
Yes, of course. But basically what happens then is that, so this is late November 284. Diocles goes back to a hill outside Nicomedia and he adopts the splendid name of Gaius Aurelius Valerius Dioclesianus. So Diocletian on this hill. He then has Appa dragged out in chains to stand behind him, tells the assembled legions that Appa is the man who killed Numerian. He draws out his sword,
刺穿了阿帕，一剑将他刺死，至此他成为了东方的皇帝。然而，有个问题，因为听众可能还记得，不幸的努梅里安还有一个兄弟，没错，他仍然留在罗马。现在关于卡里努斯的报道把他描述成一个彻头彻尾的混蛋，有点像卡利古拉和尼禄那类人。所以据说他有一连串的妻子，让每一个妻子都怀孕，然后一想到自己让她们怀孕了，他就感到恶心，于是把她们甩了，再去勾搭下一个。这只是他可耻行为的一个典型例子。这正是你在每天的互联网花边新闻栏里看到的行为，对吧，汤姆？是的，他被戴克里先的宣传人员钉在了耻辱柱上。但事实上，他
stabs Appa, runs him through, and he is now emperor in the east. However, there's a problem because listeners may remember that the the unfortunate numerian had a brother that's right who is still back in rome now the reports on carinus make him sound an absolute rotter kind of up there with caligula and near well so he apparently he has a succession of wives and he gets each one pregnant and then he's so revolted by the fact that he's got them pregnant that he dumps them and moves on to another one and this is just a typical example of his disgraceful behavior that's the kind of behavior you see on the man online sidebar of shame every day though tom yes he's he so he he is on he's put in the sidebar of shame by uh diocletian's propagandists but in fact he he he
似乎相当能干、相当高效。他召集了一支军队，从罗马出发，开进巴尔干地区，在一个叫马尔古斯的地方——也就是今天的贝尔格莱德附近——与戴克里先会面。他正处于赢得战役的边缘时，却也遭到了暗杀！哦！又来了。你可能会想，那些与戴克里先作对的人，他们的结局似乎都非常凄惨。所以他就在胜利的边缘被暗杀，而戴克里先成了唯一的皇帝。那么此时的戴克里先大约多大年纪？
seems to have been pretty effective pretty efficient and he collects together an army he marches out from rome he he marches into the balkans he meets with uh with diocletian at a place called margus very near uh where belgrade is today and he's he's on the verge of winning the battle when he too gets assassinated oh and again chances you may wonder well you know people who come up against diocletian yeah they all they all all seem to come to grisly ends. So he's assassinated just at the moment of victory, and Diocletian becomes emperor, and he's the sole emperor. So Diocletian at this stage is how old, roughly?
大约40岁。我们对他在前40年里除了军阶晋升之外的事了解多少？除了他出身非常卑微、没有任何真正的文化底盘之外，其实并没有多少了解。不过他是一个非常爱国的罗马人，对罗马城的古代传统非常虔诚。奇怪的是，与此形成悖论的是，他鄙视罗马城本身。所以，
About 40. And do we know anything about him in those first 40 years, other than the rise up the ranks? Not really, no. 40 years other than the rise up the ranks not really no apart from the fact that he is from this very humble background that he has no real cultural hinterland but he sees he he's a very patriotic roman he's a very devout uh in the in the kind of the sense of you know the ancient traditions of yeah of the roman city he despises oddly paradoxically that the city of rome itself so okay um he does not go to to Rome to have his powers ratified by the Senate. And clearly the reason for this is that he's rubbing the noses of the Senate in the
他没有去罗马让元老院批准他的权力。很显然，这样做的原因是他要狠狠羞辱元老院，让他们认清自己已经过时的现实。在他统治的过程中，他将做的事情基本上是彻底终结整个奥古斯都体制。他的统治大概将是自奥古斯都时代以来最具决定性、
fact that they're obsolete. And over the course of his rule, what he will do is essentially terminate the entire Augustan settlement. and his rule will probably be the most decisive um the most influential since the time of augustus because it will end up putting the roman empire on entirely new foundations and i think we should uh we should take a break at this point that's a great cliffhanger tom very exciting an institutional cliffhanger we don't think ever enough when we come back we'll have a look at how he did it. Great. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
最具影响力的一次，因为它最终将罗马帝国建立在全新的基础之上。我想我们此时应该休息一下。这真是个极好的悬念，汤姆，非常激动人心，一个体制上的悬念。我们觉得这种悬念永远都不嫌多。回来后，我们将看看他是怎么做到的。太棒了。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com
我们共同主持《娱乐余音》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的节目、独家加更并优先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
welcome back to the rest is history we are talking about the history of croatia well croatia ish according to tom holland so we're talking about probably I mean you could argue the most famous the most influential the most important historical character to have ever come from the lands that we now know as Croatia and that is the Roman Emperor Diocletian so Tommy has just become emperor yeah all kinds of there's been lightning bolts there's been people turning green in letters all kinds kinds of stuff carry on yeah but now diocletian is the man he hates rome but he likes romanitas i suppose it's fair to say yeah wonderfully put and um he wants to well he wants to make rome great again but he's a modern he's
欢迎回到《历史余音》。我们正在讨论克罗地亚的历史——嗯，用汤姆·霍兰的话说，是“类克罗地亚”的历史。所以我们讨论的可以说是——你可以说是有史以来来自我们现在所知的克罗地亚这片土地的最著名、最具影响力、最重要的历史人物，那就是罗马皇帝戴克里先。所以汤姆，他刚刚成为了皇帝，有各种各样的闪电，有轿子里变绿的人，各种各样的事情，继续讲吧。是的，但现在戴克里先掌权了。他讨厌罗马，但他喜欢罗马性（Romanitas），这样说挺公平的吧？说得太妙了。他想要——嗯，他想让罗马再次伟大，但他是一个现代人，
not just a traditionalist he's a modernizer as well is that right he's a kind of cultural traditionalist but an institutional modernizer. Nobody in Rome would characterize themselves as modernizers. You introduce radical reforms by saying that you're going back to the past. Yeah. And what Diocletian is doing is he's trying to get Rome back to its rugged military self that he sees as having been lost. But initially, his job is the job that's been confronting Roman emperors for at least 50 years, which is basically to try and stabilize what is absolute chaos. So there are barbarians crashing across the Danube. So that's what Diocletian in person, he goes to sort that off. There's also huge crisis in Gaul. There are barbarians that have crossed the Rhine,
不仅仅是个传统主义者，他也是个现代化者，对吗？他算是一个文化上的传统主义者，但却是个体制上的现代化者。在罗马，没有人会把自己标榜为现代化者。你引入激进改革时，嘴上总是说你要回归过去。是的。戴克里先正在做的事，是试图让罗马回到他认为已经失落的、坚韧不拔的军事自我。但最初，他的工作是罗马皇帝们至少面临了50年的工作，也就是基本上试图稳定那场绝对的混乱。因此，蛮族正冲撞着多瑙河。戴克里先亲自去解决这个问题。高卢也存在巨大的危机。有蛮族跨越了莱茵河，
but there are also basically, it's the Gilets Jaunes are making their first appearance in Northern Gaul. They're called the Bagaudai. They're objecting to the enormous amounts of tax that are being imposed on them. They are kind of coming out with their tractors and their yellow jackets and dumping manure in the streets of Lutetia and all that kind of stuff. So they need to be sorted out. And the other very 21st century Europe thing that's happened is that a guy called Carousius has launched Brexit. Of course he has. So he's a kind of, he's the commander of the Saxon shore forts.
但基本上，这也是“黄背心”运动在高卢北部首次亮相。他们被称为巴高代人（Bagaudai）。他们反对强加给他们的巨额税收。他们开着拖拉机，穿着黄背心，把粪便倒在卢泰西亚（Lutetia）的街道上，诸如此类。所以这些问题需要得到解决。另一件非常具有21世纪欧洲特色发生的事情是，一个叫卡鲁修斯的人发动了“脱欧”（Brexit）。当然喽！所以他有点像是萨克森海岸堡垒的指挥官，
So he's commanded the kind of the channel fleet. And he has declared a kind of unilateral independence. Although it's not actually a full Brexit because he sees himself as Roman as well. And he basically sees himself as an equal of Diocletian. So all of this has to be sorted out. The barbarians need to be pushed back. The Bagaudi need to be crushed. And Britannia needs to be brought back into the fabric of the Roman Empire.
他指挥着海峡舰队。他宣布了一种单方面的独立。尽管这其实算不上一次完全的“脱欧”，因为他认为自己也是罗马人。他基本上把自己看作与戴克里先平起平坐的人。所以这一切都必须得到解决。蛮族必须被击退，巴高代人必须被粉碎，而不列颠必须重新被纳入罗马帝国的版图。
And Diocletian sets about doing this very effectively in a rather novel way. So he himself campaigns in the Balkans, does it very effectively, flings them back into the wilds beyond the Danube. But he takes on a partner. So he adopts a guy called Maximian as his son and gives him the title of Caesar. Diocletian's own title is Augustus. He gives Maximian the title of Caesar. So is this the first time that happened, Tom? This is the first time that it's institutionalized. So essentially, Maximian is his partner. He is equal. And this is quite a novelty because essentially what Diocletian is saying is that he is unable to cope or anyone is unable cope, with the rule of the entire empire.
戴克里先以一种相当新颖的方式非常有效地着手解决这个问题。因此，他亲自在巴尔干地区开展军事行动，做得非常出色，将他们赶回了多瑙河以外的荒野。但他找了一个搭档。他收了一个叫马克西米安的人为养子，并授予他“凯撒”（Caesar）的称号。戴克里先自己的称号是“奥古斯都”（Augustus）。他授予马克西米安“凯撒”的称号。汤姆，这是历史上第一次发生这种事吗？这是第一次将其实控制度化。本质上，马克西米安是他的搭档。他是平等的。这相当新颖，因为戴克里先本质上是在说，他自己无法应付，或者说任何人独自一人都无法应付整个帝国的统治。
He needs an autonomous fellow emperor covering the West. He basically takes responsibility for the East. And so he appoints this guy, Maximian, to the rule of the West. And Maximian, like Diocles, is an Illyrian peasant. He's a seasoned general. He's got the kind of classic square head of the third century. Is that what people have? Balkan square heads?
他需要一个独立的同僚皇帝来负责西方。他基本上承担了东方的责任。因此，他任命这个叫马克西米安的家伙统治西方。而马克西米安和狄奥克莱一样，也是一个伊利里亚农民。他是一名经验丰富的将军。他有着第三世纪那种典型的方头。人们都是这样的吗？巴尔干方头？
Judging by the sculpture, there's a very kind of cubist trend in Roman sculpture at this point. They all have these kind of terrifying square heads and short hair, like the kind of minders that Djokovic had when he went to, when he refuses to take vaccines. The men you would expect to see outside guarding the entrance to a nightclub, turbo folk drifting down the street. Yes.
从雕塑来看，罗马雕塑在此时有一种非常立体主义（cubist）的倾向。他们都有这种可怕的方头和短发，就像德约科维奇去——当他拒绝接种疫苗时，带的那些保镖一样。就是那种你在夜总会门口看到守卫、耳边飘过涡轮民歌时会期待看到的男人。是的。
A massive German BMW outside. That kind of thing. Absolutely that kind of thing. And Maximian is a very, very effective general. He lacks Diocletian's cunning and ability to see the kind of whole, the kind of statesmanship that Diocletian comes to show. But he's an effective operator.
外面停着一辆巨大的德国宝马。就是那种。绝对是那种。而且马克西米安是一个非常非常高效的将军。他缺乏戴克里先的狡猾以及那种能够展现宏大视野、展现狄奥克莱先后来表现出的政治家风范的能力。但他是一个高效的行动者。
He goes off to Gaul. He crushes the Bagaudae. He, as Diocletian had done, pushes the barbarians back, in his case, back beyond the Rhine. And he then has to deal with Carusius, but he can't do that because he can't raise a fleet.
他去了高卢。他粉碎了巴高代人。和戴克里先一样，他击退了蛮族——对他的情况来说，是赶到了莱茵河以东。然后他必须对付卡鲁修斯，但他做不到，因为他组建不了一支舰队。
So it's a bit like Napoleon trying to raise a fleet, you know, to seize control of the channel. He lacks control of the shipping lanes and so he can't get his forces over to Britain. So Carusius is kind of thumbing his nose at Maximian and of course Diocletian. And so this brings home to Diocletian that maybe even more wholesale reform is needed.
这有点像拿破仑试图组建舰队来夺取海峡控制权一样。他缺乏对航运要道的控制，因此无法将部队运送到不列颠。所以卡鲁修斯有点在向马克西米安甚至戴克里先竖中指。这让戴克里先意识到，可能需要进行更加彻底的改革。
So in 286, he promotes Maximian to Augustus. So there are now two Augusti. And this is kind of key innovation. Two emperors. However, at the same time, it's also not an innovation because of course the idea that power should be divided between two people is actually a primordial Roman idea going back to the consulship
所以在公元286年，他将马克西米安晋升为奥古斯都。所以现在有两个奥古斯都了。这是核心创新。两个皇帝。然而与此同时，这也并非一种创新，因为权力应该在两个人之间分摊的想法，实际上是一个源自执政官职位的古老罗马核心理念，
because classically the Romans had two consuls and so this is kind of classic Diocletian maneuver on the one hand it's a radical innovation that there can be two Augusti on the other it's kind of back to the future you're going back to the primordial origins of the Roman Republic and the entire Roman state as people remember from our podcasts about Caesar crossing the Rubicon or indeed the downfall of Cleopatra, the idea of dividing power between two or more people is part of the great stories of Roman history, isn't it introduced. So there are all kinds of paradoxes lurking around there. And Diocletian proclaims himself to be the son of Jupiter. So he takes on the title of Jovius. You know, Jove is alternative name for Jupiter. And Maximian is cast as the son of Heracles. So he takes on the name of Hercules. So these are peasants who are now basically divine, they're semi-divine. Tom, can I just ask about their names? So Maximilian had been Caesar and then he's promoted to Augustus. So obviously there's a sense at this point that Caesar,
因为传统上罗马有两个执政官。所以这可以说是典型的戴克里先策略：一方面，存在两个奥古斯都算是一项激进的创新；另一方面，这有点像是“回到未来”，你回到了罗马共和国和整个罗马国家最原始的起源。正如听众从我们关于凯撒跨越卢比肯河或克利奥帕特拉陨落的播客中所记得的那样，在两个人或更多人之间分配权力的想法，正是罗马历史伟大故事的一部分，不是吗？因此，其中潜藏着各种各样的悖论。戴克里先宣称自己是朱庇特之子。因此，他采用了“约维乌斯”（Jovius）的称号。（你知道，Jove是朱庇特的别名。）而马克西米安则被塑造成海格力斯之子。因此，他采用了“海格力斯”的名字。所以这些曾经的农民现在基本上成了神，他们是半神。汤姆，我能问一下他们的名字吗？马克西米安曾是凯撒，后来被晋升为奥古斯都。所以很显然，此时有一种感觉，即原本是一个名字的“凯撒”已经变成了一个头衔。但究竟是戴克里先构想出“凯撒”将低于“奥古斯都”的制度，还是说当时已经有一种观念，认为“奥古斯都”是一个比“凯撒”更高的头衔？嗯，如你所说，“凯撒”是一个家族名字，后来成了每一个成为皇帝的人都会采用的名号。
which was originally a name, has become a title. But is it diocletian who dreams up the fact that caesar will be junior to augustus or was there already a sense that augustus was a superior title to caesar well so caesar as you say is a family name that becomes um one that is adopted by everyone who becomes emperor yeah um so it's a name that ultimately derives from the roman aristocracy but augustus is a title that conveys an almost supernatural quality. You're midway between the earthly and the divine, midway between the mortal and the human. So to be an Augustus is better than being a Caesar. Do you not think that all British prime ministers should become a Walpole?
所以这个名字最终源自罗马贵族阶层，但“奥古斯都”是一个传达近乎超自然特质的头衔。你处于尘世与神圣之间，处于凡人与人类之间。因此，作为一名奥古斯都，要好过作为一名凯撒。难道你不认为所有的英国首相都应该变成一个“沃波尔”吗？
Yeah, that'd be quite good, wouldn't it? Yeah. Some, I think it's fair to say, Tom tom would do greater justice to the name than others yes i i mean what the equivalent of augustus would be i don't know kind of god or something god yeah so if you do very well you become god otherwise you're war pole yeah i mean that kind of idea right in fact in 292 yeah diocletian makes the system even more complicated because he he he and maximian both adopt very successful very able deputies who then take on the name of caesar and they're all emperors now so you now have four emperors so you have uh a tetrarchy four rules in greek so this has always fascinated me tom i love the Tetrarchy. I think it's just so strange.
是的，那挺不错的，对吧？是的。不过我觉得可以公平地说，汤姆，有些人对这个名字的诠释会比其他人更到位。是的，我不知道“奥古斯都”对应的现代说法是什么，大概是“神”之类的吧？神，是的。所以如果你干得好，你就成了神；否则你就是沃波尔，是的，就是那种想法。事实上，在公元292年，戴克里先使这个系统变得更加复杂，因为他——他和马克西米安都收了非常成功、非常有能力的副手，这些人随后采用了“凯撒”的名字，现在他们全都是皇帝了。所以你现在有了四个皇帝。因此你拥有了“四帝共治”（Tetrarchy）——在希腊语中意为“四人统治”。这一直让我着迷，汤姆，我太喜欢四帝共治了。我觉得它实在是太诡异了。
So first of all, it comes at the end of a period in which basically emperors will be rising and falling about every two weeks or something, like British prime ministers and the present day. And it's extraordinary self-confidence on Diocletian's part to share his power with people that somebody, a lesser man, might have seen as military rivals isn't it it is and i think i think it's a reflection both on um diocletian self-confidence but also his cunning and his ability to to choose the right people so that's the key yeah he chooses people he he completely trusts but it's not just trust it's It's also people who lack the ability to rival him. So Maximian, he's a kind of solid deputy.
首先，它出现在这样一个时期之后：在这个时期里，皇帝基本上每两周左右就会起落一次，就像当今的英国首相一样。这体现了戴克里先极大的自信，他愿意与那些被某些人——比如某个能力不如他的人——视为军事对手的人分享权力，不是吗？确实如此。我认为这既反映了戴克里先的自信，也反映了他的狡猾以及他挑选合适人选的能力，这才是关键。他选择了他完全信任的人。但这不仅仅是信任，
He's the kind of guy that a mafia boss would want at his back. But he's not smart enough. He's not imaginative enough to rule the whole empire. And do the four Tetrarchs, do they ever hold kind of board meetings altogether where they discuss policy? a guy called Galerius. So the Western Augustus and the Eastern Caesar are meeting up. The empire is kind of roughly divided up. So Constantius gets the territory beyond the Alps, so Gaul, and the responsibility for finishing off Carusius. Maximian gets Italy and Africa. Galerius gets Greece and the Balkans, and Diocletian gets italy and africa yeah um galerius gets greece and the balkans and diocletian gets the rest right yeah so diocletian keeps for himself the richest provinces basically so that's
这也是挑选那些缺乏与他争夺权力能力的人。所以马克西米安，他是一个稳健的副手。他正是那种黑帮老大愿意留在自己背后的人。但他不够聪明。他没有统治整个帝国的想象力。那么这四个共治的皇帝，他们会举行全体董事会会议来讨论政策吗？一个叫伽莱里乌斯的家伙。所以西方的奥古斯都和东方的凯撒正在会面。帝国大致被划分了。因此君士坦提乌斯获得了阿尔卑斯山以外的领土，也就是高卢，并负责最终消灭卡鲁修斯。马克西米安获得了意大利和非洲。伽莱里乌斯获得了希腊和巴尔干地区，而戴克里先获得了意大利和非洲——是的，伽莱里乌斯获得了希腊和巴尔干地区，而戴克里先获得了其余地区。对，是的。所以戴克里先给自己保留了最富裕的省份，基本上就是这样。
not utterly dissimilar from the divisions that you'd seen in previous periods in roman history the basic east west kind of division i suppose it's following the fracture lines of geography so the alps is an obvious division line. The Adriatic is an obvious dividing line. Yes. And these are the fracture lines that again and again, over the course of Roman history, keep kind of splitting apart. You always want the East because the East is the richest cities,
这与你在罗马历史先前时期看到的划分并不是完全不同，那种基本的东、西方划分。我想这是顺应了地理的断裂线，因为阿尔卑斯山是一条显而易见的划分线。亚得里亚海是一条显而易见的划分线。是的。而这些正是在罗马历史的进程中，一次又一次不断裂开的断裂线。你总是想要东方，因为东方拥有最富裕的城市、
the most urbanized, all of that stuff. Yeah. But in a way that, that, that the sense that they're getting, you know, the equivalent of provinces is,
最城市化的地区，等等。是的。但从某种意义上说，他们获得的省份对等关系，
is not entire. I mean, it's kind of true, but it's not entirely true because they are all equally emper provinces. I mean, it's kind of true, but it's not entirely true because they are all equally emperors. So there's a geographical specificity, but there's also a sense that if one of them goes to another part of the empire, they're still equally emperor. And all of them are very, very successful. So all of them, like Diocletian, are Illyrian peasants, rustic, uncultured but great they
并不是绝对的。我的意思是，这有一定道理，但并非完全如此，因为他们所有人作为皇帝都是平等的。因此，这里既有地理上的特殊性，也有一种共识：如果其中一人去了帝国的另一个地方，他们依然同样是皇帝。而且他们所有人都非常非常成功。所以他们所有人，像戴克里先一样，都是伊利里亚农民，粗鲁、缺乏文化，但他们被证明是帝国伟大的公仆。
prove to be great great servants of the empire you know they're seasoned by hardship they're seasoned by war they they do what has to be done tom are you look i i never would have guessed that you would have such a a fondness for kind of balkan warlords i'm not fond of them they're terrifying figures yeah i mean they them. They're terrifying figures. Yeah. I mean, they're brutal, terrifying figures and you would not want to run up against them. But when you're in a condition where the alternative is complete collapse and anarchy.
你知道，他们经历过艰难困苦的淬炼，经历过战争的洗礼，他们做着必须要做的事。汤姆，你看，我怎么也想不到你竟然对巴尔干军阀有这样一份偏爱。我并不偏爱他们。他们是可怕的人物。我的意思是，他们是残忍、可怕的人物，你绝对不想跟他们狭路相逢。但当你身处那种“唯一的替代方案就是彻底崩溃和无政府状态”的境地时……
Yeah. I mean, it's the age old decision. What's worse, anarchy or brutal order? You know my views, Tom. I do know your views. And I think that if I was a barbarian, I wouldn't be in favor of them you know, if I was a barbarian, I wouldn't be in favour of them.
是的。我的意思是，这是一个古老的决定。什么是更糟的，无政府状态还是残酷的秩序？你知道我的看法，汤姆。我确实知道你的看法。而且我认为，如果我是个野蛮人，我不会赞成他们，你知道的，如果我是个野蛮人，我不会赞成他们。
But probably if I was a guy, you know, trying to run a business in Gaul, I'd be very keen. You're on your own double-gazing company. Smack a firm government. Yeah, you need to smack a firm government. So it all goes very well. Constantius ends up retaking Britain. So there's a famous medallion in the Britishish museum the only illustration from the roman period of london where he's shown riding in on a horse
但可能如果我是一个在高卢经商的人，你知道的，我会非常热心。你经营着自己的双视公司。猛击一个强有力的政府。是的，你需要猛击一个强有力的政府。所以这一切进展顺利。君士坦提乌斯最终收复了不列颠。因此，在大英博物馆里有一个著名的奖章，这是罗马时期伦敦唯一的插图，上面显示他骑着马进来
being greeted by uh cheering by the kneeling figure of londinium uh there's a rebellion in egypt which diocletian suppresses yeah and best of all and the real marker that rome is back there's a brilliant war against the Persians. I love a brilliant war. Fabulously well. Fabulously well. And in fact, it goes so well that Diocletian and Galerius, who have teamed up for this, actually managed to capture the Persian royal family.
受到欢呼，并受到隆蒂尼乌姆跪地形象的欢迎；埃及发生了一场叛乱，戴克里先镇压了这场叛乱；是的，最棒的是，罗马回归的真正标志是与波斯人进行了一场辉煌的战争。我喜欢一场辉煌的战争。好极了。好极了。事实上，进展非常顺利，联手进行这次行动的戴克里先和伽列里乌斯，竟然成功俘虏了波斯王室。
So again, like Alexander. Alexander captures the Persian royal family. Diocletian does the same. And the Persian king is so desperate to get them back that he agrees to pretty humiliating terms so this is um a treaty signed at a place called nisibis on the uh the roman persian frontier in 299 uh and it sees the um the roman frontier massively strengthened. So this has been a source of weakness and instability for decades and decades and decades for Rome. And now it's massively, massively strengthened. And this is probably the single most important contribution that
所以，就像亚历山大一样。亚历山大俘虏了波斯王室。戴克里先也做了同样的事。波斯国王非常渴望把他们要回来，以至于他同意了非常屈辱的条件；因此，这是在公元299年在罗马-波斯边境一个叫尼西比斯的地方签署的一条条约；这使得罗马边境得到了大规模的加强。因此，几十年来，这一直是罗马软弱和不稳定的根源。而现在，它得到了大规模、大规模的加强。这可能是戴克里先对罗马帝国稳定做出的最重大的单一贡献。
Diocletian makes to the stability of the Roman empire. It's the shores of the East. The shores of the East. And that then enables him, gives him the breathing space to turn to the kind of reforms that no emperor has had for 60 years. The functioning of the economy, the functioning of the administration, all that kind of thing. So Diocletian's reforms are incredibly significant. And they basically provide the foundations for what will become the Byzantine Empire. So they will survive the collapse of the Roman Empire in the East, and they will provide the underpinnings for Roman provincial administration up until the coming of the Arabs in the 7th century. century so these are very very momentous obviously his focus as it's been for every emperor is the army so he he increases forces he improves fortifications so a lot of the um the most impressive roman fortifications that that survive are from this period you know they're they're
那是东方的海岸。东方的海岸。这随后使他能够腾出精力，让他有喘息的空间去进行60年来没有任何皇帝进行过的改革。经济的运作、行政的运作，诸如此类的事情。因此，戴克里先的改革具有难以置信的重大意义。它们基本上为日后成为拜占庭帝国的基底提供了基础。因此，它们将在罗马帝国东部的崩溃中幸存下来，并将为罗马行省行政管理提供支柱，直至7世纪阿拉伯人的到来；所以这些都是非常非常重大的事件。显然，和历代皇帝一样，他的重点是军队；因此，他增加军队，改善防御工事。因此，许多最令人印象深刻的、幸存下来的罗马防御工事都来自这一时期，你知道的，它们
right expressive of a kind of revolutionary approach to how you defend places. And he is able to pay for this because he has simultaneously introduced a bureaucracy that is closer to that of China than the traditional Roman kind of decentralized form where you have people from senatorial backgrounds kind of rising up and employing freed men or equestrians or whatever um this is this is a a kind of a bureaucracy that obeys a um a kind of chain of command pretty much like the army well it's about to say it's a much more militarized state under the very it is so basically the whole of the Roman Empire exists to raise money, to pay troops, to defend it so that money can be raised to pay the troops. Right. So it's a military fiscal complex is perhaps the best way to put it.
正是对如何防御地点的一种革命性方法的表达。他有能力支付这笔费用，因为他同时引入了一套官僚体制，这套体制比传统的罗马去中心化形式更接近中国，在那种传统形式中，你会有出身元老院背景的人崛起并雇佣解放自由民或骑士等等；而这是一种听命于某种指挥链的官僚体制，几乎就像军队一样。嗯，我正要说，在非常……这是一个军事化程度高得多的国家。它的确是。所以基本上整个罗马帝国存在就是为了筹集资金，支付军队薪饷，保卫帝国，这样才能筹集资金来支付军队薪饷。对。所以说，这是一个军事财政联合体，也许是最好的说法。
A sort of self-perpetuating tax raising machine. Yes. And so from this point on, Roman emperors and their servants, they have a much heavier tread than emperors in previous generations had had. And he is a very efficient administrator. He restructures the Augustan provincial system entirely. So he divides the provinces up into much smaller units. Do you know the name of the people who are put in charge of these kind of much smaller units um it'll be very popular with with uh with a lot of the uh the more clerical wangs that we have um see yeah and they're called deacons no they're called vicars vicars so diocletian in the hour of the the empire's need, trusts the administration to vicars. To an army of vicars.
一种能够自我延续的税收机器。是的。因此，从这一点开始，罗马皇帝及其随从的足迹要比前几代的皇帝沉重得多。而且他是一个非常高效的行政管理者。他彻底重组了奥古斯都的行省系统。因此，他把各行省划分为更小的单位。你知道那些被委任管理这些更小的单位的人叫什么名字吗？嗯……这在我们的许多……呃……许多书吏型人物中会非常受欢迎……看，是的，他们被称为执事。不，他们被称为维卡（长官/代牧）！维卡！因此，在帝国危急关头，戴克里先将行政管理托付给维卡。托付给一支维卡大军。
An army of vicars. But there are also larger units, which are called diocese. Oh. And Italy loses its privileges, so it becomes a kind of region much like anywhere else. So it now starts to be taxed for the first time. Quick question about Diocletian. Where does he spend most of his time? He spends most of his time in Nicomedia.
一支维卡大军。但也有更大的单位，被称为管区。哦。而且意大利失去了特权，因此它变成了一个像其他任何地方一样的区域。所以它现在开始第一次纳税。关于戴克里先的一个快问。他大部分时间都在哪里度过？他大部分时间都在尼科米底亚度过。
So that's Iznik in Turkey. Yes. But he's peripatetic. He kind of roams across the Balkans and across the East. He is very, very keen on people showing him the kind of respect that people show the Persian persian emperor's respect so uh he introduces this custom of proskinesis that have been a cause of of outrage to romans and to greeks for centuries and centuries alexander the great terrible trouble with this so it's this is prostration this is uh people coming into the presence of the um the emperor have to bow they have to prostrate themselves um and this is very very not what what Augustus had done. You know, the whole thing about Augustus was that he was pretending to be a senator like anyone else.
也就是土耳其的伊兹尼克。是的。但他四处奔走。他在巴尔干半岛和东方各地游历。他非常非常热衷于让人类向他表现出人们向波斯皇帝表达的那种尊重，所以他引入了这种“叩拜礼”（Proskinesis）的习俗，这几个世纪以来一直让罗马人和希腊人感到愤怒。亚历山大大帝在这方面遇到了极大的麻烦。所以这就是顶礼膜拜，也就是人们来到皇帝面前必须鞠躬，必须五体投地。这与奥古斯都所做的事情截然不同。你知道的，奥古斯都的全部作风就是假装自己和任何人一样，只是一名元老。
This is the absolute opposite. Diocletian is insisting that people who come into the presence of an Augustus or a Caesar show the respect that is due to him as the head of the Roman state. Does that plus the bureaucracy suggest that the Roman Empire is, for want of a better word, and I know this isn't the ideal word, being orientalised? Is it becoming more Persian? Because you mentioned China, say a Chinese-style bureaucracy. Are the Romans getting a lot of these ideas from Persia and perhaps beyond that, though they might not know it, from powers further east? I mean, I think that the custom of proskynesis does come from Persia. So to that extent, perhaps you could say yes. But I think that the fact that Diocletian ends up constructing a bureaucracy that does
这完全是反其道而行之。戴克里先坚决要求任何来到奥古斯都或凯撒面前的人，都要表现出作为罗马国家元首应有的尊重。这加上官僚体制，是否表明罗马帝国——恕我直言，我知道这不是最理想的词——正在被东方化？它变得更像波斯了吗？因为你提到了中国，比如说中国式的官僚体制。罗马人是否从波斯，以及或许超越波斯的地方，从更东方的力量那里吸收了许多这些理念，尽管他们自己可能并不知情？我的意思是，我认为“叩拜礼”这一习俗确实源自波斯。从这个程度上讲，或许你可以说是的。但我认为，戴克里先最终建立起一个与中国相似的官僚体制，这仅仅反映了一个事实：在治理一个庞大的帝国时，只有某些特定的方法可行。
parallel that in China is simply a reflection of the fact that there are only certain ways that you can order an emperor, a large empire. Yeah. Reflects the fact that there are only certain ways you can structure an empire in a pre-industrial age. And that Rome had begun as a city and a republic. And in the face of the crisis that it faces in the third century, those ancient traditions are inadequate to cope with the scale of what is required. And that is why you have this kind of this heavy tread and this obsession that Diocletian shows with basically trying to impose
这反映了这样一个事实：在非工业化时代，构建一个帝国只有特定的几种方式。而罗马最初是一个城市和一个共和国。面对在公元三世纪面临的危机，那些古老的传统已经不足以应付所需规模的挑战。这就是为什么会有这种沉重的步伐，以及戴克里先所表现出的这种执念，基本上试图将秩序强加给一切。
order on everything. And he can only impose order if he has the military and the bureaucracy. He can say, do this, and they go off and do it in a way that simply hadn't existed before. And the measure of how keen he is to do this is that he starts to try and impose order wherever he sees chaos. So notoriously, one of the ways he does this, he's desperate to stop inflation, which is completely out of control. So he tries to stabilize the currency. He introduces gold and silver coinage um but he inflation still continues to raise and so notoriously he introduced in 301 he introduces this edict on maximum prices oh yeah which is quite uh i mean that's quite what it's quite harold wilson yes it is it's very heath it's
只有拥有军队和官僚机构，他才能强加秩序。他可以下令“这样做”，他们就会去执行，而这种方式在以前是根本不存在的。他想要这样做的迫切程度的衡量标准是，他在看到混乱的地方都开始试图强加秩序。众所周知，他这样做的方法之一是，他极其渴望制止完全失控的通货膨胀。因此，他试图稳定货币。他引入了金银币，但通货膨胀仍在继续上升，因此众所周知，他在301年颁布了《最高价格法令》。哦，是的，这相当……我的意思是，这相当……这很像哈罗德·威尔逊。是的，这非常像泰德·希斯。
very ted heath harold wilson richard nixon Nixon. Richard Nixon was probably from price controls by the early 70s. So essentially, what Dark Clichon is doing, he has no understanding of economics. He looks at prices rising. He assumes the only reason for this can be that all the merchants are being greedy. And so he imposes a list. Stop it.
这非常像泰德·希斯、哈罗德·威尔逊、理查德·尼克松。尼克松可能在70年代初就因价格管制而闻名了。所以基本上，克莱先所做的是，他对经济一无所知。他看到价格上涨。他认为这唯一的理由只能是所有的商人都太贪婪了。于是他开出了一份清单：住手！
This is how much things have to cost, and you're not allowed to go any higher. And of course, for economic historians, it's fascinating. People love to write about this period, don't they? It gives this complete list of what prices were, what they should be. Really, really interesting. Of course, it doesn't work. It doesn't work.
东西必须卖这个价，不准再涨了。当然，对于经济史学家来说，这太迷人了。人们喜欢写这段历史，不是吗？它提供了当时价格是多少、应该应该是多少的完整清单。真的非常非常有趣。当然，这行不通。这行不通。
But Diocletian's ambition to stabilize the currency by improving the gold content and the silver content does work. Because it's been progressively devalued, hasn hit the Roman currency although in due course the the silver standard will be abandoned the gold standard will be preserved and the gold solidus will become the basis for the Byzantine recovery in due course the other even more notorious attempt to impose order is an attempt to impose order on the dimension of the supernatural yes I thought we'd get to this so in the in the wake of the treaty of Nisibis, which he signed with the Persians, he is now able to ask the kind of theological question, why have things been going so badly?
但戴克里先通过提高黄金和白银含量来稳定货币的雄心确实起作用了。因为此前它一直在被逐步贬值，这打击了罗马货币，尽管随着时间的推移，银本位将被放弃，但金本位将被保留，金索利都斯将成为日后拜占庭复兴的基础。另一个更具轰动效应的强加秩序的尝试，是试图将秩序强加给超自然维度。是的，我以为我们会谈到这个。因此，在他与波斯人签署尼西比斯条约之后，他现在能够提出这样一个神学问题：为什么事情会变得如此糟糕？
Now that I've stabilized the eastern frontier, I can start to try and make things up to the gods who have clearly been angered. And he arrives in Antioch, which is after Rome and Alexandria, the third city in the empire in Syria. And while he's there, a Christian deacon called Romanus, he comes from Caesarea just down the coast, tries to stop sacrifices to the gods. This, for Diocletian, clarifies everything that's been going wrong. There are groups of people that have emerged who are disrespectful of the gods. This for Diocletian clarifies everything that's been going wrong. There are groups of people that have emerged who are disrespectful of the gods, who don't believe in the gods, who are scorning them. There are people called Manichaeans who are followers of a Persian
既然我已经稳定了东方的边境，我就可以开始设法向那些显然已经发怒的神明们进行弥补。他抵达了安条克，这是继罗马和亚历山大之后叙利亚帝国的第三大城。当他在那里时，一个名叫罗马努斯的基督教执事，从海岸边的凯撒利亚赶来，试图阻止对神明的献祭。对戴克里先来说，这澄清了所有出错的事情。已经出现了一些不尊重神明的人群。对戴克里先来说，这澄清了所有出错的事情。已经出现了一些不尊重神明、不相信神明、对神明嗤之以鼻的人群。有一群被称为摩尼教徒的人，他们是一个名叫玛尼的波斯先知的追随者。
prophet called Marni. So Diocletian launches a campaign of persecution against them. But Romanus is a Christian. And so it's the Christians that become the main focus of his ambition. So Romanus himself, he has his tongue cut off. He's taken to prison. He's executed. Diocletian and Galerius, and again, you asked, do they meet up? Absolutely, they do. Diocletian and Galerius have a consultation about what they should do about the Christians. Diocletian is happy just to stop Christians from being allowed to hold office. Galerius wants to go much further. He says we should have a campaign of extermination. And Diocletian says, well, we should consult the Oracle. So they go to the Oracle of Apollo at Didymus. And Apollo says, yeah, go for it. Go for it. Go flat out. So February 303, Diocletian by this point is back in Nicomedia. There's a church that had
因此，戴克里先对他们发起了迫害运动。但罗马努斯是个基督徒。因此，基督徒成为了他雄心的主要焦点。所以罗马努斯本人被割掉了舌头。他被关进监狱。他被处决了。戴克里先和伽列里乌斯——再次说明，你问他们是否会面？当然，他们会面了。戴克里先和伽列里乌斯就如何处理基督徒的问题进行了商议。戴克里先乐于仅仅阻止基督徒担任公职。伽列里乌斯则想走得更远。他说我们应该进行一场灭绝行动。而戴克里先说，嗯，我们应该去请教神谕。于是他们去了狄迪玛的阿波罗神谕所。阿波罗说，去吧。去干吧。全力以赴。因此，公元303年2月，戴克里先此时已回到尼科米底亚。那里刚刚建好了一座教堂，他下令将其夷为平地。第二天，他颁布了针对基督徒的法令。是的。臭名昭著的法令。是的。
just been built there and he has it raised to the ground. And the following day he issues an edict against the Christians. Yeah. Notorious edict. Yeah. So by the terms of this edict, all the scriptures are destroyed. Every Christian is required to hand over their scriptures. And so the people who do this are called traditores, which means people who hand over. And so for Christians, devout Christians, these traditores are traitors. And that's where we get the word traitor from. It's from this time. So a traditor is originally someone who hands over scriptures tom that is one of the the best facts i've learned in all these all these episodes of the rest is history it's a it's a top
根据这项法令的条款，所有的经文都被销毁了。每个基督徒都被要求交出他们的经文。因此，做这件事的人被称为“traditores”，意思是交出经文的人。因此，对基督徒、虔诚的基督徒来说，这些“traditores”就是叛徒。这就是我们词汇中“traitor（叛徒）”一词的由来。它源自这个时代。所以一个“traditor”最初是指交出经文的人。汤姆，这是我在《历史其余部分》所有这些节目中学到的最好的事实之一。这是一个顶级的事实。一个伟大的……教堂……
fact it's a great um church it's continued to be pulled down yeah and christians are banned from assembling um to worship and in the immediate wake of this this the publication of this edict there are a series of fires in the commedia uh sections of Diocletian's palace get burnt down. And Diocletian assumes that this is Christians. And in fact, he regards Nicomedia as being so unsafe that he leaves. So he sees himself basically as a target of kind of terrorism. And so he sees the persecution of Christians as a war on terror. And when Christians are captured, they are
继续被拆毁。是的，基督徒被禁止聚集做礼拜。紧随这项法令颁布之后，尼科米底亚发生了一系列火灾，戴克里先宫殿的部分区域被烧毁。戴克里先认为这是基督徒干的。事实上，他认为尼科米底亚太不安全了，于是他离开了。因此，他基本上把自己视为恐怖主义的目标。因此，他将对基督徒的迫害视为一场反恐战争。当基督徒被捕时，他们被极其残酷地处决。其中一些人在火上炙烤。这段迫害的记忆将在教会的记忆中存留非常非常长的时间。我的意思是，直到今天依然如此。戴克里先的迫害被铭记为绝对是最残酷的。尽管我认为其背后的动力是伽列里乌斯。真正比戴克里先更具敌意的是伽列里乌斯。戴克里先确实把他的名字签在了上面。然而在西方，马克西米安和君士坦提乌斯，
executed very horribly. Some of them are kind of roasted over fires. And the memory of this persecution will live very, very long in the memory of the church. I mean, it still does to this day. The Diocletian persecution is remembered as absolutely the worst. Although I think the motor for it is Galerius. It's Galerius who is really, even more hostile than Diocletian. Diocletian absolutely puts his name to it. However, in the West, Maximian and Constantius,
他们并没有真正推行它。所以真正残酷的是东方，那是绝对最糟糕的。他们在西方没有推行它，部分原因是不是因为基督徒较少？这没那么大不了。它没有那么都市化。也许基督教并没有像在东方那样蓬勃发展？
they don't really push it through. So it's really in the East and it's the absolute worst. Do they not push it through in the West, partly because perhaps there are fewer Christians? It's not such a big deal. It's not so urban. Maybe Christianity hasn't taken off as much as it has in the East.
这是一个原因吗？是的，这可能是原因之一。我也认为他们只是没有那种意识形态上的敌意。没错。那种戴克里先似乎拥有的敌意。所以这一切都是一种激进的、激进的改革过程。它彻底且永久地改变了罗马帝国，但戴克里先认为自己是一个传统主义者。因此，在公元303年11月，
Is that one reason? Yes, it may be. I think also that they just don't have the kind of ideological animus. Right. That Diocletian seems to have had. And so all of this is by way, it's a radical, radical process of reform. It transforms the Roman empire utterly and permanently, but Diocletian sees himself as a traditionalist. And so in due course, in November 303,
他第一次也是最后一次访问罗马。我的意思是，他可能在统治的最早期非常短暂地访问过罗马，但我认为这不太可能，因为他似乎将这次访问罗马视为一种庆祝活动，庆祝他恢复了罗马人民的传统习俗并因此恢复了他们的传统伟大，因为对戴克里先来说，这两者是互为表里的。因此他前往罗马，庆祝他统治20周年，并举行了凯旋式——这也是罗马最后一次庆祝的异教凯旋式。对。
he visits Rome for the first and last time. I mean, it's possible that he visited Rome very fleetingly in the very early months of his reign, but I think it's unlikely because he seems to have viewed this visit to Rome as being a kind of celebration of the fact that he has restored to the Roman people their traditional customs and therefore their traditional greatness because the two for Diocletian are mutually independent. And so he goes to Rome and he celebrates the 20th anniversary of his rule and a triumph that is the very last pagan triumph to be celebrated in Rome. Right.
但他讨厌罗马，他对吉本所称的“罗马人放荡的亲昵”感到震惊。噢不，他们对做了什么？不。所以在年底前他就离开了。那是十二月，天气很冷。他着凉了，病情日益加重。他在次年十一月到达尼科米底亚，公开露面后随即晕倒。人们担心他会死，但他没有死。但在公元305年3月，他重新出现，但他已经完全形销骨立了。两个月后，他来到了那个曾被宣告为皇帝的山丘上，
But he hates Rome and he is appalled by what Gibbon calls the licentious familiarity of the Romans. Oh no, what are they doing to him? No. So he leaves by the end of the year. It's December, it's cold. He gets a chill and he just falls increasingly ill. He gets to Nicomedia by November the following year, makes a public appearance and then collapses. And it's feared that he's going to die, but he doesn't. But March 305, he reemerges, but he's an absolute shadow of himself. And two months later, he goes to the hill where he had been proclaimed emperor,
在那里他获得了戴克里先（Diocletianus）这个名字。在那里，他破天荒第一次退位了。因此，他是第一个放弃紫色长袍（皇位）的罗马皇帝。好吧，这可以说是整个故事中最不同寻常的细节了，汤姆，他放弃了自己的指挥权。是的，这是连奥古斯都或提比略这些第一代皇帝都没有觉得能够做到或者想要做到的事情。提比略我想某种程度上确实想过这么做，我想如果这是一个选项，他会去做的。但他没有，他没有。他不知道。
where he'd taken on the name of Diocletianus. And he there, for the first time, for the first time ever, he abdicates. So he's the first Roman emperor to give up the purple. Well, that's the most extraordinary detail of this story at all i think tom that he lays down his command yeah which is something that not even augustus or tiberius those first emperors had felt able or had wanted to do tiberius i think kind of did want to do it and i think if it had been an option he would have done it but he retires he doesn't he doesn't. He doesn't know.
而提比略说，嗯，你知道的，你这是骑虎难下。当你成为皇帝时，你就像是揪住了一只狼的耳朵。所以你不能松开耳朵，因为一旦松开，狼就会转过头来撕咬你，把你撕成碎片。但戴克里先确信自己不会被起诉。他不会被起诉，没有人会来找他的麻烦。确实如此。我认为这反映了他对自己所挑选的人的信心，以及他的希望——正如他为军队和文官建立了一套非常清晰的晋升循环机制一样，同样的事情也会
And Tiberius says, well, you know, you can't, you're holding a wolf by its ears. When you're emperor, you're holding a wolf by its ears. And so you can't let go of those ears because if you do, the wolf will turn and savage you and rip you to pieces. But Diocletian was confident that he wouldn't be prosecuted. He wouldn't be, no one would come after him. He is. And I think that that's a reflection in his his confidence in the people that he's chosen and in his hope that just as he's instituted very clear kind of cycles of promotion for the military and for the civil service so the same thing will
发生在……罗马世界的统治者身上。因此，曾担任他凯撒的伽列里乌斯成为了奥古斯都。马克西米安也同时退休了吗？是的。马克西米安和戴克里先一样被要求退休。他不喜欢这样。他一点也不想这样做。他认为这是一个荒谬的主意，但他不得不这么做。现在的问题是，既然伽列里乌斯和君士坦提乌斯已经成为了奥古斯都，谁来接替他们担任凯撒？是的，他们需要选择自己的副手。我想他们原本以为他们的儿子会接任。因此，君士坦提乌斯的儿子是一个叫君士坦丁的年轻人。
happen with with um with the rulers of the roman world so galerius who had been caesar to him becomes augustus and does maximian retire at the same time? Yes. So Maximian is required to retire as Diocletian does. He doesn't like it. He doesn't want to at all. He thinks it's a ridiculous idea, but he's obliged to. Now the question is, who will succeed Galerius and Constantius as Caesar now that they've become the Augusti? Yeah, they need to choose their own deputies. And I think that they had assumed that their sons would. So the son of Constantius is a young man called Constantine.
而当戴克里先交出皇位时，君士坦丁就和他在一起，在尼科米底亚郊外的那个山丘上。但君士坦丁并没有成为凯撒。是一个名叫马克西米努斯的人成为了凯撒，继承了已成为奥古斯都的伽列里乌斯；而在西方，则是一个名叫塞维鲁的人。因此，这就产生了一种内在的不稳定性，因为那两位已经成为奥古斯都的凯撒的儿子们，他们的角色是什么？
And when Diocletian resigns the purple, Constantine is there with him on that hill outside Nicomedia. But Constantine does not become Caesar. It's a guy called Maximinus who becomes Caesar in succession to Galerius, who in turn has become the Augustus. And it's a guy called Severus in the West. So there's an inherent instability created there because the sons of the two Caesars who've now become the Augusti, what is their role?
而君士坦丁设法溜走了，他去投奔正忙于平定不列颠的哥哥（译者注：此处播客原意为父亲君士坦提乌斯）君士坦提乌斯。随后，君士坦提乌斯将在约克去世，君士坦丁将直接宣称继承他的统治，这将带来重大的后果，我确信我们以后会做一期节目来讲述君士坦丁。我们会做关于君士坦丁的节目的。然而与此同时，戴克里先退隐回到了他的家乡，他回到了达尔马提亚，
And Constantine manages to slip away, and he goes off to join his brother Constantius, who is busy pacifying Britannia. And in due course, Constantius will die in York, and Constantine will lay claim directly to his rule with momentous consequences that I'm sure we will do an episode on we'll do episodes on on constantine however diocletian meanwhile he retires back to his homeland so he goes back to dalmatia um and he goes back to uh salona and he he builds a huge pack he's been building a huge palace there and it's it's built like a kind of fortress he grows his cabbages there yeah he famously grows cabbages yeah and maximian wants to come back. Maximian, he's retired to Southern Italy. He kind of writes
回到了索洛纳，他建了一座巨大的宫殿，这座宫殿就像一座堡垒一样。他在那里种卷心菜，是的，他以种卷心菜而闻名，是的。马克西米安想回来。马克西米安已经退隐到意大利南部，他给戴克里先写信说：“你知道的，让我们把乐队重新组建起来吧。让我们重新开始巡演吧。”而戴克里先说：“你知道的，如果你能看到我亲手种的卷心菜，你肯定就不会想这么做了。”他在312年去世。我想他是很长很长一段时间里第一个在自己的床上安详去世的皇帝。到这个时候，很明显，他建立的四帝共治体制已经失败了，因为内战再次爆发。随后，君士坦丁将作为唯一的统治者、唯一的皇帝崭露头角。但正如我所说，他绝不是一个失败者，因为他所提供的框架使罗马帝国在经历这场近乎死亡的体验后得以存活下来。在第四世纪，这是一个极其强大且高效的帝国实体，非常非常非常强大。
to Diocletian and says, you know, let's get the band back together. Let's get back on tour. And Diocletian says, you know, if you could see my cabbages that I've grown with my own hands, you wouldn't want to do that. And he dies in 312. And I think he's the first emperor for a very, very long time to kind of die in his own bed. And by this point, it's evident that the tetrarchal system that he set up has failed because civil war has broken out again. And in due course, Constantine will emerge as sole ruler, sole emperor. But as I say, he is very much not a failure because the framework that he provides enables the Roman Empire to survive this near-death experience. And in the fourth century, it's a ferociously strong and effective imperial entity, very, very,
他建立的宫殿——宫殿的拉丁语是“palatium”。是的。随着时间的推移，“palatium”这个词缩小演变成了斯普利特（Split）。因此，“斯普利特”这个词源自戴克里先的宫殿（palatium）。它是罗马考古学中最伟大的遗址之一。哦，确实如此。对于不知道的人来说，如果你去斯普利特，它就在海滨，非常宏大。我的意思是，宫殿的走廊和大厅现在变成了斯普利特这个老城区街道，两旁都是商店、餐馆、冰淇淋店等等。但你仍然可以看到……我的意思是，你绝对就在宫殿里，在宫殿的轮廓中。这是一座最令人惊叹的建筑。如果你喜欢罗马人，或者确实如果你喜欢巴尔干冰淇淋，这里就是去的最完美的地方。所以我想这对克罗地亚旅游局来说是一个绝妙的结尾，我希望他们能赞赏这一点。
very, very strong. And the palace that he has founded, so the Latin for palace is palatium. Yeah. And in due course, palatium gets shrunk to become split. So the derivation of split is the palatium of Diocletian. And it's one of the great sites. Oh, it is. Of Roman archaeology. For people who don't know, if you go to split, it's uh you know it's it's one of the great sites oh it is of roman archaeology
正如我所说，戴克里先是罗马历史乃至整个欧洲和地中海世界历史上非常、非常、非常重要的人物。所以希望你们喜欢这期节目。多米尼克，我确信我们还会做更多关于晚期罗马帝国的节目。噢，这太迷人了，汤姆。我非常喜欢这个时期。我们绝对必须做一期关于君士坦丁的节目。但在此期间，希望你们喜欢这期节目。我们肯定会回来的。
for people who don't know if you go to split it's right there on the waterfront it's huge i mean that the corridor the halls of the palace are now the streets of this sort of old quarter of split and they're lined with shops and restaurants and ice cream parlors and what have you but you can still see the app i mean you're absolutely the right there in the palace in the outline of the palace it's the most amazing building if you like the romans or indeed if you like balkan ice creams it's the perfect place to go so i think that's a brilliant end for the croatian tourist board and i hope that they will they will they they'll appreciate that um and uh as i, Diocletian, very, very, very significant figure in the history of Rome
我们明天会回来。后天也会回来。我们永远不会离开。永远不会离开。我们就像躺在轿子里努梅里安的尸体一样久久不散。这不是我对这个播客的看法，但我接受它。好的。大家再见。
and indeed in the history of Europe and the Mediterranean world more generally. So I hope you enjoyed that. I'm sure, Dominic, that we will do more on the late Roman Empire. Oh, that's fascinating, Tom. I love this period. We must absolutely do Constantine, for instance. But in the meanwhile, I hope you enjoyed that. And we will definitely be back.
下次见。大家再见。下次见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
We'll be back tomorrow. We'll be back the day after that. We're never going away. Never going away. We are lingering like the corpse of Numerian in his litter. That's not how I thought of this podcast, but I'll take it. Okay. Bye-bye, everybody.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝秀场八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、加更节目和提前购买现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。这期节目暂时还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留下评论。
See you next time. Bye-bye, everybody. See you next time. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
下次见。大家再见。下次见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works We have just launched our Members Club if you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和提前
access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
获取现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。